so yet again it's another birthday in
the computer world another home
computers got its 30th birthday so we
have the Mac in 2014 we have the Atari
ST in 2015 we probably should have done
the Amiga in 2016 but we didn't and this
year it's the Acorn Archimedes could ask
the question is boring dr. Bagla
because this is a British computer but
why would anyone know arrestor will know
that this computer they probably
wouldn't know about the computer
directly they probably know a lot about
the prices are in it so a couple years
ago we did a video on the 30th
anniversary of the processor I think
only half the 12 billion arm shipped in
the last year went into mobile phones
because this was the first computer ever
to use the arm CPU the arm CP was
developed because of this computer right
it was developed to drive a calls next
generation and this is what they
developed this is what came out of that
development yet let's find one still in
its original box this way just like
normal everyday yeah absolutely
quite going as well but you know a
comment asking what kind of list evolved
actually so it's a serious cybernetics
lift I did want to go to do weird things
beautiful day there when a person you
want to tell what it is
right we're going this way
and we're going to my secret hiding
chamber on my secret the doll is amazing
another our community still in its
original box which is one I bought off
eBay a couple of years ago the world's
half made by is it's actually still into
original box but this is probably one of
the earlier models of it because when I
can't release the Archimedes in 87 there
were four different versions released I
think one of the never actually left the
market but there was the a 300 series in
the 84th one hundred series the 400
series is a professional model and to
come with one mega RAM or four mega RAM
and a hard disk in front of it the a300
is aimed at the home user or schools
came with 512 kilobytes of RAM or one
mega grams oh that's the 305 but there
are other machines in the range the
Archimedes 310 is also a BBC micro when
I got this on off eBay it was advertised
as essence a 1 Meg machine but I
realized looking at the box and the
serial number on the bottom it
originally been a 512 K machine which
had then been upgraded at home made 1987
in the UK we weren't using this one
we're going use the one upstairs because
it actually works with better this one
but got an earlier version the operating
system on we're gonna have a chat about
what this machine did and why it was
certainly in the UK and very very
popular in the UK any one of a certain
age will be very familiar with these
because they were bought by pretty much
most schools in the UK so everyone's
will use them as a kid the interesting
thing about the Archimedes lies it
continued the tradition of being a BBC
micro certainly the a310 on the a 305
did so they have the red function keys
which was a staple thing they were also
used by the BBC on screen as well so
lots of TV shows Doctor Who another
primetime shows if they needed a
computer it would often be an acorn
computer perhaps rebadge with some
fictional brand and so on has appeared
on there doing whatever it was needed to
do but I also use behind the scenes
often linked up to
external software to generate the
graphics using lots of primetime shows
when kids would phone in play the little
on-screen game yeah yeah yeah your phone
ugly - left left right Giants so all of
those were actually done using the acorn
archimedes computers we talked about me
being on Tony but actually the thing you
have to remember at this when it came
out this machine was incredible for the
time at the time we came out it was a
home computer it sold for less than a
thousand pounds and it gave you form it
four million instructions per second
worth of computing power that's roughly
the same amount of computing power that
you could get into my probably the Sun
workstation that we looked at in the
previous video that one three one sixty
which is pretty top-of-the-line 486 was
probably about the same sort of powers
you suddenly got in a home computer and
actually at the same time son introduced
a spark CPU and was starting to move to
risk-based architecture so the nice
thing about this is the RISC machine
when it was originally released it had
an operating system called Arthur don't
ask why no one really knows that
basically was very sim as what was on
the BBC micro except that he did support
Windows mics and so on so he's got the
same sort of user interface it wasn't
really used for at all on the original
release that came with the later version
which was renamed to RISC OS which you
can still get today in store on your
Raspberry Pi so the operation still
available and it generally works you
have multi tasking cooperative rather
than pre-emptive so if one program will
sort of carried away doing something and
didn't relieve control to everything
else then you sort of had to wait for it
to finish but it all booted up out of
ROM so they turned on and off very very
quickly and you get started within
seconds so it's got to came along about
89 with sort of some of the later
versions of the machine and it continues
you could upgrade it so these machines
have the RAM upgraded form bag it's got
an arm three card in it's got acorns
local area networking in there and
things in the scuzzy card which gives it
some nice big hardest thing yeah it was
a really nice machine first time you
could also get a version that ran UNIX
so acorn ported UNIX to it not Linux
that I'm going to really have a proper
UNIX to run on this machines and so you
had actually quite a powerful set of
machines that were released at that
point certainly with the arm three trip
there is powerful as many other
UNIX workstations at the time if not
more so of course technology marched on
them for the produce later version so
you got sort of less interesting looking
versions with the a 5000 which Alex you
to do a few videos years ago the design
of these is quite nice this one's got
the two drives I like it and then of
course you've got Laker machines which
Sean is very familiar with which was of
course the risk PC this is the sort of
the the end of the line for the
Archimedes ranging lost the Archimedes
badge and looked a bit like a
PlayStation 2 before the PlayStation 2
when in fact all computers started to
look like this because Atari had a
prototype that had this sort of wedge
shape effect but yeah this is the one
that I should let Sean talk about what
this one really got used for holy
gangster I shall give you a quick yeah
your sensibilities it keeps track amides
being the wrong side of the camera for
movement one of my first jobs and one of
the reasons I got so heavily into
computing is I used to help install this
kind of machine at television stations
so I used to go round the world
installing them places like Moscow
Johannesburg Seattle you name it I've
been there and often put one of these
machines in so this is a version of what
the company I work for used to sell and
what we used to love about them was they
were to Leslie you could get into them
very quickly and easily and they were
pretty much instant on a bit like Steve
just mentioned that the OS was in ROM
which men they didn't have to wait for a
hard disk to spin up to load in the
operating system they just kind of
turned on and worked so right I
forgotten how to put it back on so let's
leave it for a minute Steve can show you
inside and talk about a bit more
technically but we used to use them for
on-air television automation so very
very kind of time critical application
and you want it you needed confidence
from the people writing them
so these things fantastic for that the
systems move through to using Windows
and Macs and all sorts of stuff since
then but certainly in mid to late 90s
early 2000s and even now some of these
are still in operation transmitted
in television programs I'm not sure I
could name any because I haven't worked
in that area for a while well the
interesting thing that you initially
notice about this is that when you run
an application
let's run the drawing application
whichever kid used to so if you get what
is effectively equivalent to the dock
that's in OS X or the Start menu that is
in Windows from 95 on so the folklore
goes is that someone went from working
with a core machines like this to
Microsoft and took his acorn with him
and apparently was seen and they decided
that to wear the windows 95 Start menu
was going to come from somewhere across
bump whether I believe that or not but
that's certainly how the folklore go so
you end up with the icons down here and
you could then so we have any grafton
certainly by risk of three it came with
the applications built in to Rome and so
you could load them up very very quickly
and so you could start to draw pretty
pictures you had Bezier splines in there
so again from 1987 this is the original
welcome system perhaps the thing that
the arm asked me to express released was
most famous for was a demonstration or
game that was on the actual welcome disk
as actually released as a full game to
have this all done that so here's what
happens when you try and run 1987
software on a machine operating ticket
from 1993 even though he was out of date
so let's find a slightly later version
of the welcome disk we use the other
drug that's just showing off too floppy
guys are absolutely yes on that list of
at work somewhere I've grabbed the area
under the sake of applications just
the copy of replication 'disformed serie
a backup copy so sometimes he for please
wood dies he often would make backup
copies let's try this one as what
helpful and so there's this game called
lambda which became the full games arch
and when this game was released it was
sort of full 3d graphics which was not
really seen like this and the idea was
he had to sort of fly the spaceship
around the this was just a demonstration
and I was never any good at it I
remember being blown away by this yeah I
think everyone was when it came out and
this was a sort of a demo again you've
got the 87 through there I should buy
David Brabant of elite fame who they
might want him to be involved with the
creation of the Raspberry Pi this
originally came out and everyone said no
you couldn't do this on anything but the
akin Arthur means because he knew the
power
it was later ported to the game virus to
the st and the Amiga and then in a true
bizarre turn affect someone actually
ported it to run on the ZX Spectrum on
an 8-bit machine with the four megahertz
fragrances so perhaps they were ever but
certainly the the a conversion on the
Archimedes was the smoothest the
controls was controlled by the math and
it's incredibly sensitive so even on the
launch pad if you're not careful you can
blow things up and you can sort of
explore because you're also an
interesting sort of clipping issues
there is the house sort of fall through
the land escape unlike you know that and
there's definitely claims with about I'm
sure if you look in the right place if
you could find copies of the disks and
arm and you later
and Archimedes emulator to run it on
yes it's a bit like the old moon lander
game used to get victory now game over
and so that we no more computer files
assurance too busy playing games on the
Archimedes